saturne nintendo playstation ou encore
game boy des jeux vidéo qui nous
accompagne depuis les années 1970
l'exposition 50 ans de pixels retrace
les jeux d'hier à aujourd'hui borne
d'arcade mais aussi première console
avec les ordinateurs qui n'avaient pas
de disque dur ni de carte graphique
puisque tout était à l'intérieur du
clavier les jeux vidéo ont bien évolué
mais certains ne se passe pas du roi des
troqué le flipper ou les confie ce donc
ça me rappelle lui il est venu pour voir
l'ensemble des jeux vidéo qui existe
surtout actuellement et d'ailleurs il à
l'étagé on n'est pas un endroit puis moi
je retrouve ma jeunesse au travers du
flipper par exemple auquel je jouais
quand j'étais jeune dans les cafés au
fil du 20e siècle on observe des
changements renversant dans le profil
des joueurs en france
la moyenne d'âge est passé de 21 ans en
2000 à 35 ans en 2015
c'était des ce qu'on joue à la maison
c'est un peu nostalgique et ça peut
intéresser que des vieux comme nous
parce que les jeunes ils vont
directement à l'efficacité fin 2010 est
une console est venu complètement rompre
les barrières la nintendo switch qui
peut se jouer en version salon ou
portables mais passer d'une époque où le
jeu vidéo était assez cloisonnée entre
les gens qui jouaient les gens qui ne
jouait pas et la wii a complètement
ouvert le spectre de personnes qui
jouent aux jeux vidéo et aux combats les
familles acheter de jeux vidéo parce
qu'elle voulait faire des petites
parties avec les enfants on en a mis
dans les maisons de retraite pour la
rééducation et cetera ça vraiment
complètement ouvert le public
le jeu vidéo est en 2018 trop connu pour
son apport à la culture il inspire
toutes les industries et tous les arts
l'exposition 50 ans de pixels se termine
le 19 décembre à la maison 2 co villes
de voisins-le-bretonneux